ag pas de jeu pour aujourd'hui [ __ ] la
page blanche mise à jour est un bon
compte et pour moi ça va faire cinq
jours passent à faire des mises à jour
d'os ou fédéral est frère d'anna bonjour
bonjour on est surtout cialdi ou saisie
du code
comment ça va on est sur la mise à jour
d'une autre crise doivent vous êtes tous
torché fait pas semblant aujourd'hui tu
peux la télécharger gratuitement c'est
une mise à jour ses messages en est on
va pas faire tout les gens à faire la
moitié de la mise à jour à faire dix
questions ces syndiqués ce tube sur 20 à
oviedo sûreté match intéressant un pli
sauf proposition de psp et bryan habana
est lui tombé dans tes mails
alors voici la mise à jour merci merci
ça me fait très bien j'ai hésité à faire
cette vidéo en échange de son diamond
button mais il est à ton bureau donc je
viendrai voir la remise à connaît les
frères reconnaît lé pa frère ce par la
galerie qui est le nom de ton studio de
jeux vidéo exactement où on est
parfaitement 2 à ça commence avec une
pub un babouin non mais on reconnaît les
vrais ans reconnaît les fossés part
c'est parra mais le jeu est gratuit 1 1
ce jeu à l'air bien donc on va on va
peut-être une vidéo là dessus allez avec
un nikon de slips pour ces nouvelles
questions tu es revenu pour souffrir
encore plus génial tu as déjà vu 114
n'opter vraiment nul à bath et toi 114,9
à ton propre josé choc annuler les
parties je suis partie 61 son jeu
j'appuie sur le slip quelle personnalité
n'a jamais fait de pub pour whisky ah
ouais en fait j'avais dans la tête musca
serait donc savoir quelle personnalité
n'a jamais fait de pub pour du whisky
david beckham bill murray jude law
bruce willis y en a trois qui ont qui
ont fait des pubs produce il y en a
trois qui ont fait des pubs pour ruffier
je dirais franchement mec david beckham
c'est un sportif un peu ici tout ça et
ben voilà bar fait pas partie finalement
pour celui ci l'a fait mais si je vois
bien bossé ces gamins de whisky à la
main et vu joe a bien cru jusqu'à la
main c'est que quel talent il ya
beaucoup de beaucoup de stars a donné
une rupture effectué assez ouf enfin
c'est pas toi un truc qui se fait tu
vois les après jérôme charlebois
toulouse mais non on fait là bas tu m'as
dit par contre panache et sa branche
vins bio suisse est bien la seule
personnalité à n'avoir jamais fait de
publicité pour du whisky il en a fait
pour de la vodka
ah oui bon finalement
il y avait un truc l'aqueduc annexes
trouve le vrai logo usb
maintenant je connais et j'aime réveil
choisie en bas à droite pour le plus
évident mais le smiley qui branchent à
paris attends je crois que c'est à temps
est ce que vous savez vous derrière
votre écran
oui je parle comme un vieux c soit
celui-là soit cela celui où le trait du
milieu il ya une flèche vous déjà c'est
sur eux
chaque cellule what he no life [ __ ]
mais j'hallucine wetenhall à l bravo à
je vois que vers le reggae qu'est ce que
tu peux regarder un ordinateur il ne
s'allume plus non tu appelleras
l'assistance pour computer question 63
lesquels de ces villes d'islande
n'existe pas aux gens envie d'aller en
islande du coup ces personnes souhaitent
faire voyager
ouais bah ouais tout à fait genre qu'en
provence on va pas ce mytho poitiers
j'en ai pas mal pour l'instant
franchement impressionnant c'est vrai le
coût du logo usb je suis [ __ ] parle un
guide mais qu'est ce qui nous arrive est
ce que les genres et vous en faire un
meilleur score que moi me met vraiment
c'est le deuxième film raconte un homme
blanc découvre un nouveau monde celui
d'amitié avec les autochtones les ses
confrères veulent tout ravager avatar le
dernier samouraï au kansas dance avec
les buts et 7 au dessus
non j'ai vu qu'un bain avatar non en
vrai avatar c'est ça aussi d'un homme
blanc qui découvre un nouveau monde les
hommes bloquistes et d'amitié avec eux
mais ses confrères évoquent démonter les
hommes bleus c'est le pitch du film
ayvaz plusieurs ok d'accord a fait tache
la gamme avec danse avec les loups ça
mais qui découvre un luis mais pas telle
que et c'est pas de bol du thé les loups
ne l'a pas vu alors cette histoire je
connais pas vers nous ouais ouais non
c'est tout ce jour là tu me fais honte
et c'est aussi une sorte de tarzan la
route d'eldorado la boîte il a laissé sa
colère
[Musique]
[Rires]
[ __ ] ça je suis toujours très très nul
relie ces animaux dangereux à leur
territoire
du coup j'ai peu de donner un indice
ils sont tous presque très très mortels
sauf qu'au bout d'une mare à 7 avec
l'iphone doive noire à dos rouge ça
pique cl d'eau était bleu tu vois ça
passe
ah oui le modèle basé sur un domaine
boucher est né sur un dos rouge venant à
dos rouge gérait pas je dirais que c'est
un truc genre d'amérique du sud
ben voilà c'est rapide je dirais que
c'est un truc d'afrique centrale sont en
fait il trop de chatte ouais tu perds
donc à eddy du plus ça doit être
australie 7 jan ouais c'est ça [ __ ]
les mecs j'aurais dû me douter certains
d'iphone alors le serpent ipad ça fait
vachement chinois tan dun ça fait
vachement afrique centrale ou non je
cèderai pas fait quand même vachement
des halles baltard il avait
embouteillage tu peux à relier deux à un
seul [ __ ] la blague c'est bien tout ce
qu'on y voit là ok j'arrête c'est le
pays où il ya le plus de dents a été
limogé et très bizarre ce fait j'ai un
cousin qui est parti en australie ça
fait longtemps que je n'ai plus de
nouvelles de lui d'ailleurs j'ai trop
envie d'y aller mais c'est vraiment le
truc qui me bloque c'est ça en fait
c'est le fait que la faune et la flore à
la fête soit extrêmement lourd je peux
être mangé par une plante collabos quels
ingrédients ne figure pas dans la
recette du coca cola sulfite d'ammonium
ça c'est un truc qui te ronge tous ceux
qui sont un peu fade
physique chimie n'est ce pas bonnes
notes de sodium chlorure de potache et
c'est ça non bonjour j'ai un peu chez
lui ce club a déjà utilisé comme poison
pour les peines de mort aux états unis
comme ça qui ne trouvera pas un coca
cola a bon on n'est pas loin comme ça
c'est vraiment le truc létale tu sais
quand il ya pas voilà merci pour cette
anecdote soit en avec aisance hors
d'abstention soit ancien classé du plus
ou moins dangereux mangez cinq fruits et
légumes par jour
moi je pense que tu as regardé effet que
ça peut avoir sur le corps ces tumeurs
révéler un secret de la nasa ou un pique
nique à fukushima je m'en suis né à
fukushima mais esclave and spa australie
qu'est plus alors c'est bon c'est bien
fukushima devenait un secret de la nsar
of oui et ils vont en australie moi
j'aurais communes vivent en australie
avant tout on est très délicatement la
pièce en bois l'espèce des fois j'en
étais sûr rabat
attends mais ces médias l'on devrait
honorer pour cette question oh oui oh
[ __ ] mais maigre mais capela mon gars
tu à transpercer un mec de l'autre côté
de la tour d'ayem pas fait gaffe bravo
mr le cadeau attention qu'est ce qu'on
va avoir ses golden share golden c'est
le groupe diamond automne bah non c'est
mieux que damon boutonne c'est des super
vacances au soleil
c'est vrai allez on va la suite nous
n'aurons pas pas au top
le mérite et c'est pour vous les
internautes la suite voilà c'est la
télécharger je fais un petit peu la
promo gratuite attention agression
aviation tu as toujours c'est un jeu
gratuit c'est disponible sur android et
ios et c'est très plaisant et il reste
plein de trucs à faire et à voir des
mises à jour très bientôt aux tats riche
et là oui j'ai entendu de voir une
prochaine mise à jour avec des pics de
ouf qui vont arriver ça on le garde sous
des robes idex quoi qu'il arrive à faire
son discours tout en tendant ses joues
pas le mec il est trop fort eh ben les
amis n'hésitez pas venez vous ça vous a
plu
n'hésitez pas à faire ces questions là
et à faire les dix suivantes voilà nos
si vous n'avez jamais joué au jeu c'est
gratuit faire voilà tous vos faire tuer
des choses handisport et puis en sortir
je remercie cyprien pour lui j'ai
beaucoup ri j'ai beaucoup aimé j'ai
encore moins envie d'aller en australie
où j'adore les changes pour lui dès lors
il nous reste encore du très lourd aussi
sur balles et que les questions qui est
qu'on n'a pas encore fait et puis les
prochaines mises à jour
là encore je veux pas spoiler là pour
l'instant d'aller les modes de avec les
niveaux tu vois on va voir un nouveau
mode est un nouveau mode de jeu genre qu
american league
ils ont ils sont passés du foot au
basket de roquettes et les obus est là
c'est alors par les aviations regarde et
me souviens tu as tout le monde
[Musique]
ça